the marvel cinematic universe has had
plenty of highs over the past decade
like avengers end game
and the occasional lows
nobody gets my pants but there's one
universal truth that every single fan
can get behind
miss minutes is brilliant and loki the
mascot
ai helps run the time variance authority
also known as the tva
she also charmed viewers from the
instant she was introduced
loki first sees the animated character
in the informational videos playing in
the tba's waiting area
basically miss minutes is a splash of
brilliant creativity in the cosmic
bureaucracy that makes the idea of the
tva go down a little easier for
audiences in the series first episode
however many viewers of the show quickly
deduce that there is much more to miss
minutes than meets the eye towards the
beginning of the show's sixth episode
the adorable clock is revealed to have a
direct line to the man behind the
curtain
he who remains when loki and sylvie
manage to enchant their way into the
citadel at the end of time
miss minutes rebels and offering the
pair everything they've ever wanted in
exchange for taking over the tva
miss minutes might be some kind of
virtual ai but she's clearly got a
devilish side
something she's likely inherited from he
who remains the script originally gave
miss minutes much more to do in the
season finale
in fact she was supposed to fight loki
and sylvie when they arrived in the
citadel
unfortunately the closest viewers
actually got to see in a battle with
miss minutes was a jump scare and a
couple of quickly drawn weapons
but how exactly would a fight scene work
in this context it's not clear how miss
minutes can affect the real world
although we did see loki try
unsuccessfully to swatter with a
magazine in the second episode of the
season
director kate herron opened up about
this cute yet sinister character to
marvel.com
she explained early on in the scripts we
all were definitely united on we've got
to keep miss minutes in the story
somehow
the director pointed out that she tempts
both of the variants with all they've
ever wanted
that devil on the shoulder and trying to
attempt both loki and sylvie
it was fun that you got a sense of
there's something a bit more sinister
going on here with her
you want the infinity gauntlet yours
throne of asgard no problem
and according to heron miss minutes
almost got a bigger role in the finale
we always had a version where loki and
sylvia kept meeting her at the citadel
at one point we had a fight scene with
miss minutes in the citadel because much
of loki episode 6 was dedicated to he
who remains explaining exactly who he is
in exposition heavy monologues it's easy
to see why the focus was on the new
villain
we're all villains here still it's
obvious that there are plenty of fans
who would like to see more of miss
minutes in the future
and it's easy to speculate about the
character and her role in both the tba
and the marvel multiverse as a whole
now that the season finale of loki has
blown the doors off the sacred timeline
who's to say that we won't see an
expanded role for the charming ai
considering her connections to he who
remains we wouldn't be shocked if she's
full of previously unheard information
about the tva
and the multiverse so even if miss
minutes doesn't get more screen time on
loki there's certainly room for a cameo
in another marvel project
with season 2 on the way it would be
criminal for miss minutes to not return
so here's hoping she finally gets a
fight scene in the next batch of
episodes
if that's not in the cards don't fret
there's too much love for her from the
show's creators to ignore the potential
for another appearance
even if she isn't the focal point of a
branching timeline she knows enough to
cross over to another world
just as she has into the hearts of
marvel fans check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you